another kind of weather more traditional
way to think about whether is what the
air is doing on planets that have
atmospheres and moon doesn't have an
atmosphere so we don't think about him
whether Mars has an atmosphere jupiter
has an atmosphere Saturn Uranus Neptune
a couple of moons have atmospheres so so
when you study those you see interesting
patterns you see storms you see Eddie's
which are these are tiny littles spiral
patterns of air that might be their
version of a tornado and so I think you
can only really deeply understand
whether on earth once you study the
weather on other planets a planet that
rotates faster than Earth when rotates
less fast when it has higher gravity
lesser gravity and you can see the full
range of how weather takes shape in the
full spectrum of planets that are out
there and then you find out where earth
fits
hello that's why that's that way because
this is what happens in that extreme and
that's what happens in the other extreme
so that's really what
when I think of space whether that's
what i would like to reflect on
tornadoes are way more fun and
snowstorms and if you just watching
weather phenomenon tornadoes or are any
seni cyclone just to think about the
energy it contains and what it's doing
with that energy
what in the weather system was the
precursor conditions to that storm way
more fascinating to study the snowflakes
coming out of the sky
[Music]